[Music]
like him slowly
staying school three things to keep you
off the floor your tires your shoes in
your bed we should never go cheap on
them stay relaxed they call and I lay
your mind get the best to you if
somebody doesn't want to be bothered
with you then you shouldn't be bothered
with them that is from my grandmother my
Italian grandmother theater rich guy my
cousin nothing about it
to thine own self be true
keep a journal treat everybody with
respect forgive quickly have appropriate
expectations be brave and work hard I'm
a sinner and I need Jesus in my life to
be saved good response time to go life
is not an audition you only get one
so enjoy it don't take anyone elses
advice
everything in the moderation don't be
extra the best advice I haven't been
given was to keep going the only way out
pay attention to myself and it's about
the journey not the destination
in Spanish take care of the pennies and
dollars to take care of themselves I
have no regrets in your life because you
want to be the person that you are today
if you do
don't pee anywhere heard sorry don't pee
everywhere I had a problem I okay don't
judge people never fall in love with
those same person twice love everyone
loved you
I give advice I don't take it
good
[Music]
[Music]